the grey man is netflix's most expensive
movie ever and for a good reason nine
whole action sequences that's double
what you usually get well with all that
action comes some incredibly dangerous
stunts to film the training is so you
get the feeling in your body number one
sometimes you just can't fake it that
tram sequence was incredibly dangerous
they were dealing with actual explosions
and running on moving trams this was no
green screen cgi moment james young one
of the film's stunt coordinators said of
course stunt work isn't just a series of
story structure discussions there's also
plenty of running and jumping involved
the massive prog chase that sees gosling
escaping a greening tram had the actor
leaping off of life-sized tram models on
a sound stage albeit with wires attached
and full supervision by a team of
professionals
number two the end of shooting may have
well just been the most dangerous ryan
gosling was running along the top of the
train while all the train cars fell out
beneath him he felt that that was just a
bit crazy you always have to be
suspicious of what they leave for the
end of shooting what is left for the end
is generally the most dangerous because
if something happens to your star at the
end you can probably fudge your way
through the movie but if your star gets
broken and battered halfway through
filming good freaking luck
number three this one looks more fun
than it was the gray man falling out of
the plane was a very complicated process
the fight in the c-130 aircraft was
pretty tough james young said to put us
in a small tube with a car and then have
five military special ops types was a
fun thing to play with but logistically
that was difficult with cameras space in
there is very very tight
number four what counts as a little
tussle chris evans managed to walk away
with just a bruise after getting into a
staged little tussle with ryan gosling
well not just any bruise a huge bruise
on his arm he posted it's like watching
the leaves turn in autumn but condensed
into one painful afternoon as long as
you put the punch right there i can
parry at the last moment
number five sometimes actors are living
the dream other times that dream is a
nightmare
spending two days in a boiling hot trunk
is always fun trying to figure out how
to get hit with a dart and then fall
into the trunk is more of a challenge
but oh the heat is probably one of the
most dangerous things for actors who are
overworking themselves as it is at least
they weren't done up in marvel's
superhero costumes you could probably
cook an egg on a super suit number six
while some people are learning to cook
or garden anna is learning to sword
fight and shoot guns while anna barely
had to learn a thing for the bond film
for the grey man she spent months
preparing and while all of her stunts
are super impressive and so well
coordinated the only question we have is
where can we get that beautiful floral
suit she also had her fair share of gun
training literally every building she
walks in explodes either that's an
insult or the best compliment in the
world there you go better
number seven why is this something we've
always secretly wanted to try gosling
would have done his jump out the window
differently if given a chance he just
went too safe with it which he felt made
it look a little too much like a stunt
person doing a stunt it's also my first
time
leaving a room through the window number
eight cirque du soleil has nothing on
the gray man joe russo put it best when
you do these movies they're really
physically demanding it requires a
different skill set from an actor it
requires frankly a more varied skill set
and you have to commit to training this
stuff is like cirque du soleil it's
highly specialized physical work you're
throwing a punch within an inch of
someone's face at full speed if you miss
if they step wrong you're going to hurt
somebody or you're going to get hurt and
you're doing this day in and day out for
months on end you are training at like
the highest level
number nine so let's talk for a moment
about just how safe this set
actually was
because there were very few injuries and
a ton of safety protocols in the grand
scheme of things honestly filming this
movie was just a slog because a two
minute action scene could take weeks on
set so in honor of that let's just talk
about gosling's pepper spray moment for
example it looks like i'm getting
sprayed with avion which is what's
happening we thought this was
interesting because gosling felt that
his acting just wasn't authentic enough
he couldn't sell that his eyes were
actually on fire
kind of hard to do when it's the
opposite element in your eye
number ten nine action sequences means
nine chances to injure yourself it's no
secret that the grey man is the most
stunt heavy action movie ever when most
other films are only able to handle four
action sequences but even still with all
these stunts and an actor who's never
been in an action movie before
ryan gosling got off seriously lucky
with only a minor injury i've done films
that have action anymore
but i've never done an action film and
the theory is it's his dance training
that helped him through all the combat
just barely getting out
of it unscathed
gosling did have an ex-delta force
advisor helping train him on the job
despite all the safety protocols it
doesn't take much to get injured and
well chris evans hit gosling right in
the mouth with a gun on evan's first day
of filming nice to meet you too chris
director joe russo said people are
throwing punches at each other at a very
high speed and if somebody misses by an
inch somebody has a broken jaw it
requires incredible precision and a lot
of training you have to imagine trying
to memorize a fight for one action
sequence let alone nine seven months of
ryan's life were just moving through
really intense highly specialized
choreography so it's very easy to
you know to get your right and you're
left confused in situations like this
you just don't get enough time to do the
old left right hand trick to make sure
you're in check
number 11 filming while injured must be
such a pain in the neck
while training for the grey man shoot
danoosh sprained his neck just one week
before they started filming he was
pretty panicked having only one week for
physio to get back to top working
condition and he was worrying he
wouldn't be able to keep up with on his
speed danush said but somehow they found
a way to make me fit for the stunt
sequence one crick in the neck and we're
out of commission for two days so we
feel that pain
number 12 it must just suck to not be
able to rest and recover properly
anna was powering through the pain of
four ribs out of place to film these
fight sequences that she feels take a
long time and can be incredibly
frustrating to film because there are so
many micro details that need to be in
place for them she just found the
situation painful and infuriating and we
can't blame her we have a hard enough
time getting out of bed the morning
after a workout let alone doing stunt
scenes with injured ribs okay so as far
as action movies go the grey man was
golden in the safety department
considering what's happened on the sets
of movies like harry potter the russo
brothers and all of the actors and stunt
people need a standing ovation for
executing nine stunt sequences so
successfully ah
you miss your fingers
are you impressed let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things